Welcome to the Bad Language Guide to Kubernetes.
In each of these short videos, I will
teach you three things that you may or
may not know about Kubernetes.
So with this being episode one, I thought
it was only fitting that we start with
the atomic unit of all Kubernetes workloads,
the pod.
Did you know that they were not always
called pods?
The first commit to the Kubernetes project was
on June 2014 by Joe Beda.
And just two days later, Brandon Burns on
June
pushed four pull requests,
renaming
two pods
from tasks.
Why?
Well, I can only speculate. But back then,
Kubernetes only had a single runtime,
Docker.
The mascot for the Docker project was a
whale.
What do you call a group of whales?
A fucking pod.
When you're learning Kubernetes,
you'll often work with pods that only have
a single container,
and it's not even uncommon for people to
use the term pod and container interchangeably.
Pods can run multiple containers,
but it's not something that we encourage often.
There are some very specific use cases.
And, also, did you know that Kubernetes
ships with a default that only allows you
to run 110
pods
on any given node. It's there to stop
you doing something that you're gonna regret or
to stop you doing something stupid,
but it is configurable.
And you can set it to whatever you
want,
you know, for when you feel that you
know better than the experts. However,
do you know what's not got a limit
on it?
The number of containers in a fucking pod.
Let's take a look. Alright. So what we
have here is a deployment YAML
with a replica set to a 20.
I'm just gonna apply this, and we're gonna
wait
oh, I'll wait a few minutes. You can
wait a few seconds.
Okay. And we can see that it it's
kind of stuck at a hundred and five.
So let's see how many are pending. You
know, we're we're gonna expect that to be
with a quick grep.
And if we describe one of these pods,
we'll see that it cannot be scheduled because
there are too many already running on a
single node cluster.
Alright.
But I've got one more fail
in this directory.
Pure
little pod.
No deployment. No replica set. Just one single
pod.
So let's let's apply it.
Oh,
this pod has 3,498
containers.
So while we have a 10 pod restriction
per node for our safety,
you can do whatever you want with the
containers within a pod.
Let's keep an eye on this and see
what happens.
So it's never gonna fulfill its pod destiny.
seems to be a better limit.
So you can apply a pod with any
number of containers to a Kubernetes cluster.
I'm not sitting along lunch
and run,
but you can do it.
So while this pod at three and a
half dozen containers,
There is no limit.
I was able to fill a pod YAML
file
with upwards of 8,000
containers.
Kudos
to KCS,
which did block it,
but
only after 4,000.
Okay. One last thing. Now I'm pretty sure
if you've worked with Kubernetes for any considerable
amount of time,
you may be familiar with what I'm about
to show you now.
Pod specs
are immutable, at least partially immutable,
and that you're not supposed to really work
with pods directly.
You're supposed to leverage higher level obstructions like
the deployment, the stateful set, the daemon set.
However,
a few things are
modifiable.
So let's get this back into a happy
condition.
All things good.
Now
we can upgrade the image
on any of our containers
like so.
Oh, mutated.
So you can work with pods
even if only slightly.
Not that I would recommend it. Be a
good citizen.
Don't fuck with pods.